DERRICA WILSON: This little girl
had just gotten off the metro
with her mom.
We were passing out flyers.
She just stopped.
She was staring.
I asked, "Do you know her?"
She looks up at me and she says,
"She looks just like me."
Every time I look
at this picture,
it makes me emotional.
♪ (SOLEMN MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
NATALIE WILSON.
There's so many missing
people of color in the US.
African Americans remain missing
four times longer
than White Americans.
That number is alarming.
NATALIE: We hear from families
all the time,
"The police is turning us away,
the media wouldn't respond."
I'm looking for
our missing daughter.
DERRICA: And it drove me
and my sister-in-law, Natalie,
to wanna do something about it
to help these other families.
Because, if not us, who?
NATALIE: It's our job
to bring them home.
(PHONE DIAL TONE)
AUTOMATED VOICE:
Thank you for calling
Black and Missing Foundation.
SPEAKER: The police was like,
"How you know she
just ain't leave?"
SPEAKER 2: The detective
kept saying, "She ran away."
And I'm like,
"She didn't run away."
It was like a punch in the face.
When a Black person is
in distress, missing,
it's not a big deal
to law enforcement
because they don't think
we have much to lose.
This one always gets me.
Just remembering
when she was a little girl.
You blame yourself
because it's never enough.
My sister went missing in 2009.
Of all the major news stations,
nobody would talk to me.
Gwen Ifill coined the term
missing white woman syndrome.
If you don't
meet those criteria,
blonde hair, blue eyes,
your stories are not newsworthy.
SPEAKER 3:
Here's my niece. She's missing.
Her story is just as compelling.
SPEAKER 4: We have nothing
for our missing people
except Black folk's spit
and grit.
That's why I'm on ten right now.
And this is not one and done.
We will be back.
DERRICA: We don't want families
to ever give up on hope.
NATALIE:
One year, five, ten, 20.
We have seen miracles happen.
DERRICA: These men and women
that are going missing
look like my siblings
or look like my parents
and my grandparents.
They matter.
Our community matters.